- Have a seat.
(audience clapping)
I like your blue.
I like your whole outfit.
- Thank you.
I didn't make it myself.
- But you're wearing it well.
- Thank you very much.
- Yes.
- This is so funny.
There's so many musical
talented people out here
and I don't know how to-
- Do you sing?
Want me to put you on the spot?
I'm kidding. (laughs)
- You know how like you...
(audience laughs)
Can you sing right now?
You know how like you grow up in a family
where everybody sings
and you're around people
who sing all the time-
- Yeah.
- And then it's inherited?
That didn't happen to me.
- Oh.
(all laughing)
I am the opposite of that. (laughs)
- Are you tone deaf?
Or you just like don't sing?
- I can go-
- Can you you go, "Aah..."?
Can you match that? Aah..
- No. No.
Aah...
(all laughing)
I made the noise.
- He said, "Aah..." (laughs)
- By the way, you're so
good in "Uncut Gems".
- Oh, thanks! That's not-
- I loved you in it.
(audience claps)
- It's such a musical thing,
but she's so good in it.
- [Kelly] It is. I know.
- I know, sorry. Go ahead.
- No, you go ahead.
- The first-
- I talk a lot.
- So the first job I ever did as an actor
was in "Bye Bye Birdie", the musical,
you know, "Bye Bye Birdie"?
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
What'd you sing in that?
- I dunno.
- Have you seen that yet?
- I was in the chorus.
(all laughing)
There was only like four guys
in the chorus when I did it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, you had to
do rehearsal and everything,
and I didn't know how to
sing, so I used to lip sync.
I used to just do, I'd be like...
I'd mouth it
(all laughing)
because if anyone heard it, as soon as...
And then I'd be like, maybe I can sing.
Maybe I'll just give it a try,
and I'd be like going steady.
And then right away,
the vocal coach would be
like, "Oh, we're flat there".
Something-
(Kelly laughs)
- Something happened.
And I'd be like, oh, I dunno what to do.
And then I'd just mouth it again,
and then as soon as I'd sing again
she'd be like, "Ooh, we
got some work to do".
(all laughing)
So that's-
- But she wouldn't say anything
when you were lip syncing
and nothing was going out? (laughing)
- Nothing. No, because they sounded good.
I sounded so bad.
- Oh, I see what you're saying.
- Right, whenever he joined
in, there was a problem.
(all laughing)
- I'm sorry, it's a little late.
- That's why I don't even
know how to put it into words
how I can't sing, but I'm
in awe of all of you people.
I don't know how you do it.
- Well, I am an awe of you.
I'm not supposed to do this,
but I'm jumping right to it
because I love the show so much.
- Oh.
- I think it's so good.
"61st Street" is the show.
- Yep.
- And it's so important.
It's such a great, important piece of work
I think, that's going on right now.
Like, it's very intense.
- It's very intense.
I mean-
- 'Cause it's real.
- Yeah. It's happening, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah, like those kind
of situations are happening.
- And I think (stammers)
we're so lucky to get to do this job.
So it's like to do something
that actually matters.
And I think sometimes with
the news and everything,
you kind of get desensitized to it.
So when it's like a story you're watching,
I think actually you start to
identify with it a bit more,
and it shows the line between morality
and what's right and wrong,
on such a large scale.
- And then there's like some obvious
just like way wrong. (laughs)
- Yeah. Like way, way, way wrong.
- You're like, "How
did they miss the line?
It's not gray." (laughs)
- Exactly, and how did no one
notice that that was wrong?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that's the thing
that really drew me to it,
it's an important show
that I think you need to...
I mean, there's a line on the show
where Courtney B. Vance
says we need to learn
to walk in one another's shoes.
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm.
- I think that is so important.
- Oh, 100%.
Did you do like a ride-along
to get into the role or anything?
- I did do a ride-along and you know,
I'm always nervous.
I've done a few ride-alongs before
when I played police officers,
and I'm always like a bit...
You kind of want some action to happen,
but you really shouldn't
want that to happen.
- Yeah, then you kinda feel like a jerk,
'cause you're like-
- Yeah. Yeah.
I'm like, "Maybe's this
one's gonna rob a bank".
I'm like, why would I want that?
(all laughing)
I just wanna flick on the siren,
but every time I'm
around a police officer,
I always feel like I did something wrong.
You know, you're always like...
Like my posture gets better-
- Absolutely.
- When a police officer arrives.
- Or you pull off next to him at a light,
and I'm like, "Everything's good, right?"
- Yeah, and I'm like, "10 and
two, everything's going well.
Here's my registration, just in case."
So I didn't ask to throw the siren on,
but you do learn a lot.
It's like just being
around, the way they move
and stuff like that is something
that's important to me.
It's like the way they walk,
the way they handle themselves,
the way they just do everything.
It's second nature to them.
- Yeah. Have y'all...
You've gotta see "61st Street".
I know y'all ain't seen
anything down there.
(all laughing)
So.
- You got us again.
(Kelly mumbles)
(all laughing)